it's a trip made by football's first
class to the end of the business end of
the football season
[Applause]
at this champions league final once
again it's liverpool swaggering towards
the showpiece
last week liverpool missed out on the
league championship this week europe's
big trophy would deliver a treble on top
of the carabao and fa cup we've got
around the european cup and to be honest
with you the european cup's the biggest
of the trophies isn't it so we've come
all this way to see us do it again
i think
the real madrid we will win 2-1
i hope and i do see liverpool pulling
through in the end but it will be tight
this game wasn't meant to take place at
the stand of france the original plan
would have had liverpool and their real
madrid opponents training and playing at
st petersburg in russia
uefa moved it here to paris because of
the conflict in ukraine which hangs over
this occasion still
that the game still happens
and is not in saint peter's book maybe
it's exactly the right message
what russia should get
um
life goes on even when you try
to
destroy it
so and um we played this final for all
the people not only but as well for all
the people in the ukraine
of course there is the small matter of
the opposition real madrid know a thing
or 13 about lifting the european
champions trophy that's how often
they've won it and to get here
they beat chelsea and manchester city on
the way
[Music]
memories will be made here in paris
legends 2
the men in red are standing on the
threshold of a seventh european cup and
in the city of love they're loving it
for now
james matthews sky news in paris